The Joe Rogan Experience that was a
phenomenal performance in Brazil against
Glover Tashara in his hometown last
minute like I mean how much time did you
have to prep for that I had about six
weeks oh you did have six weeks but it
was well but you knew that it was a
three it was supposed to be three rounds
and then they changed it to the title
for five rounds right no no so they
think it was a title that was right
after Anka live and young behovah so
right from there legitimately called me
while they were still wow yeah while
they were still in the gauge if you
wanted a full camp for a five-round
fight though what would you what would
you prefer like how much time do you
really need I prefer maybe about like
eight weeks eight to about eight to ten
weeks so slightly abbreviated but your
performance was phenomenal man I mean it
was it was amazing to see you pick apart
Glover like that and to do so well on
the ground too I mean that was a big
victory yeah I mean a lot of people
thought that I couldn't do it I couldn't
I couldn't well that was just a general
assumption was that I couldn't I
couldn't grapple on the ground and
things like that when that's definitely
but you get in that General assumption
from who though people online
just uh picks like you know I mean just
like people like like an analyst then
like any like the fighters or whatever
that I talk to her like they'd be like
oh like they always say it's always
something that they say even guys in the
division you know they were like oh he's
just a boxer you know I don't know if he
can really wrestle or if he can really
ask like kicks or anything like that
they're questioning the kicks too you
know so this is that's some of the
biggest moments in the fight that left
high kick yours yeah well people are
going to question you until they can't
anymore right that's how it goes you
know there's always I don't know about
this guy and then all of a sudden he's
the best ever you never know right and
that's why I'm that's why I'm just
hungry for you know I mean I mean for
names man I'm hungry for the next
challenge what did it feel like when
they strapped that thing around your
waist
man this is it's a hard thing to
describe it was just like
like
almost like unreal like almost like
living like almost like like in a dream
like yeah dreams that I've had you know
and it was just like I don't know it was
crazy just a weight of everything that I
did and been through and everything was
just it was a lot yeah it seemed like a
lot it's a lot for everybody I mean
that's a moment that very few human
beings will ever achieve there there's
there's it right now
yeah that was he like that's when he
told me that he was about to retire
I mean it's amazing how long that dude
has hung in there he was the boogeyman
for six years you know for six years
Glover lived in Brazil and he couldn't
get a visa and this was like in the
early days like when Chuck Liddell was
the UFC light heavyweight champion
that's how far back Glover goes right I
heard something about like he went he
went pro in 2001. yeah crazy right crazy
22 years later
and then still fighting for a world you
know I haven't that fight with Europe
prohaska where he lost the title I mean
that was a crazy close fight until he
got caught in that choke he was ahead I
think he was yeah he was ahead in that
fight yeah I believe it was that video
that you made
to Yuri was hilarious we played it on
the podcast yeah man
that's what she said
that was the first thing that came with
my head whenever he said I'm coming now
now I can't guys he's ruined he's ruined
the phrase for me now because now I
can't say it at all no matter what
somebody called me like oh I'm coming
I'm coming I exist he's an odd duck
yeah that dude's an odd duck he's
strange he's very very different do you
see like when he was fighting Glover and
Glover was beating him up he was like
good job good job yeah like tapping him
on it I thought it was like well you
can't do that man it looks like you're
tapping like what are you doing he's
like good job good job he's but he's
saying good job and I I think it was was
it Mark Goddard it was a referee I think
it was Mark Goddard whoever it was was
warning him it's like hey don't [__]
slap him and say good job you can't do
that just what a weird thing to do guys
on top of you raining blows down you're
like good job good job like
yeah bro I don't I don't know the only
thing I can think would be possibly it
could be like just like a tactic trying
to make it seem like all like no matter
what you're wasting your time right type
thing like yeah try to like get in their
head because I think even like with the
whole Samurai thing like he wants to
play he obviously wants to wants to this
image to be believed yeah like that but
you know I just seen him when I was at
the pi a couple days ago and he he's a
nice dude you know he he walked up he's
like nice to meet you things like that
and then like I came back from actually
I was going into PT and he was working
he was like he's like I'm I'm working on
it I mean working trying to be like I'm
like taking time do your thing he's
already had the shoulder surgery right
uh I don't know I would assume if he's
already trying to reach yeah I'm sure he
has because apparently his shoulder was
the worst shoulder they'd ever seen the
UFC doctors had never seen a show that
[__] up before do you know what
happened to him
his shoulder went out of socket in
training camp and they tried to put it
back in oh yeah and these dudes are
yanking on it these just gym dudes
yanking on it and they [__] it up way
worse yeah that's never a good idea yeah
go to a [__] doctor man hey you're a
world champion world champion and he had
to give up his title like that well it's
interesting that he did decide to give
up his title he could have held on to it
and he could have had an interim title
and you could be fighting him for the
Undisputed title but instead he's like
nope I'm gonna give up my title that's
why I said he's an odd dude that's
strange because that's not only like a
like I don't think that's normally like
like not only like a bad move Legacy
wise that's a bad Business movie yeah
because now in your next fight you fight
as a challenger yeah you don't get the
you don't get the same pay-per-view
bodies you know you know I mean you
don't get the same amount of money or
none of that so yeah it doesn't make any
sense I mean I could imagine the thought
process behind it like you want to be
Noble but uh you gotta take care of that
money bro you got to take care of your
money I mean how many world title fights
you get if you're lucky if you
everything goes perfect and he should
know now especially being injured like
hey this could happen and you could get
a catastrophic injury and you could be
out for a year or so you never know I
think it was a play of him trying to be
Noble just trying to be Noble trying to
like you know oh he does the right thing
what he respects the warrior I like how
you're thinking about it like 3D chess
like what is this [__] doing for
real I'm trying to tell you man I think
a lot of what he does is meant to put a
certain image in your head you know so
I'm sure
I mean makes sense it would be smart to
do I mean he's got a weird image he's
out there throwing kicks at trees right
you know it's like wraps a tree up in a
foam pad and starts punching it and
kicking it like yelling in the woods
yeah like okay man you know gems are
better gyms are definitely better than a
tree I want to know what it is about
being in the woods that just makes him
wants to yell
[Laughter]
are you upset with the trees
do you just feel alone
do you want to be heard right right
right yeah let me do is it does it make
you more more
noble or sophisticated to be in the
woods I don't know what is it remember
when Rocky was training for for Drago
and Rocky IV went to the Woods running
in the snow carrying logs and [__]
it makes me feel weird just even saying
it out in the I'm coming video
damn it
I don't know another one that's what she
said this is crazy where you at though
this is the video by the way
that's what she said
no and the one that he did though it's
like a ax in the in a uh in a tree stump
in the background yeah did you notice
that no I didn't notice that yeah Bros
probably out there chopping wood yeah
oh I don't know look at him
I'm coming
it is [__] weird it's like okay so I
guess I wouldn't ask
yeah I might have been high when I said
it could have just been that post right
there yeah I don't see your ax
he's a strange cat man that's a strange
man that was just like
yeah I don't know man
I'm coming do you think he's next if
they have any conversations with you
about who who's gonna be your first
title defense as the champion of the
[__] world
sounds good sounds good right and you
earn the [__] out of that too yeah man
it was uh
and broken over was Glover was tough man
oh he's so tough like
like y'all said that right I think we
need to put a little bit more emphasis
on it because like
it's not just that he's tough he's tough
he's tough and while he's being tough
he's still fighting intelligently hmm
you get what I'm saying yeah so like for
for not one second did I hit him with
something and it was like oh [__] I was
like oh I don't want to get hit with
whatever's next cover up like you know
what I mean like that that one like oh I
need it I need to find like protection
type right he never did that you know
and I was just like crazy because it was
one sequence like I think it was like in
the third where I hit him with right
hand right hand
elbow left hand it's like at no point
was he like oh [__] I need to cover up
right or anything because like I mean I
finished you at that point right it's
like bro
that was in the ground and pound
sequence yeah when you're on top of it
that was so close a lot of referees
would have stopped it a lot of referees
were stopped there I mean you were
dropping bombs on him but yeah he kept
moving kept moving he kept trying to
waste he kicked me in the face from the
bottom yeah he grabbed my arm and pulled
me like he's gonna try to pull me in his
guard and then when I went in as soon as
I like so obviously to not go in you're
gonna sit up I set up he kicked me in
the face
yeah he's a crafty fella yeah man I
think his time with uh Alex pajera
really improved him too towards the very
end of his career when he started
training with LX because it like there's
something about like having that dude in
Camp with him and he's on the Run for
the middleweight title that it all like
came together and you know some of his
last fights were some of his best the
yamahovich fight you know I mean uh
you're the Yuri prohaska fight like
there's [__] great fights man yeah he
um he's harder to hit he's harder to hit
clean
than I thought because he turns his face
a little rolls with you yeah yeah a
little a little bit of that but it's
like it's his hands right so he
definitely learns from from people that
he fights because he was definitely
doing a little Jon Jones to me you know
the little like gonna kind of kind of
poke kind of poke his hands out and you
watch it a couple times like I wanted to
follow up with some shots with some
combos but the way he was like blocking
he's like going like this or like
putting his elbow up like this and kind
of like poking his fingers like Jimmy
his fingers like towards my like face
so yeah that's a weird gray area right
the you know because John poked a lot of
people in the eyes yeah you know I'm
sure he didn't mean to do it but that
style of doing it like that of having
the hands out especially when you're as
long as John
that's a you know it's a very TR it's a
very gray area you're not supposed to do
that yeah no you're not supposed to do
it but
it's done it's done it's done it's done
quite a bit you know especially like if
you see somebody get hit with something
like solid and they start like kind of
get crowded and they want to get some
space or they want to try to really
keep you from coming forward that's the
first thing that does yeah
what could be done about that though the
eye pokes the only thing that I think is
a change of the gloves they have to
figure out something to make a better
glove that doesn't encourage your hands
to be open
you know I mean we talked about this
before but Trevor Whitman um you know a
gay cheese trainer he's got a way better
glove he he makes his own material Onyx
he makes his own gloves and shin pads
and they're [__] Top Notch but he
made a better glove and I don't know why
the UFC is not using it I don't know
what's going on I don't know if they
have to get it approved by the
commissions I don't know what the deal
is but it's a far superior glove does it
affect the grappling yeah no no it
doesn't but it it keeps your hand curved
like the natural state of it is to have
your hand in a curved position versus
open with the UFC gloves you put those
on your hand wants to be open and you
have to kind of close it and tighten it
down with with his gloves it starts out
in a folded position like it's much
easier so even if you're like extending
your hand you would extend it like what
you would if you had a tie glove a
boxing glove on right you know
I just think there's got to be something
there's so many [__] eye pokes me you
guys both poked each other yeah
accidentally the only difference is when
I poked him in the eye it helped him
all right because I need because that
knee that knee I can't even went right
in the sternum right before that if if I
actually am able to put the frame on him
like I want to he's eating a head kick
you know what I mean so yeah so yeah
saving with me whenever I poke whenever
he poke me in the eye though I was on
his ass
I think I just landed like uppercut yeah
I just landed like an uppercut I was
right after a little weave the little
weed sequence here
a smooth how many times have you watched
it how many times you watched it I
watched it a few times I lost it a few
times I was just uh there's this one
little sequence in the beginning at the
beginning towards the end of the first
round where it was just I remember it
happening in the fight but I wanted to
see how it looked on camera and it was
it was like pretty smooth oh listen it
was a very good performance it was very
you were very crafty that was the the
thing about the fight that I really
enjoyed is like watching your setups and
all your faints and luring them in and
the way you're moving in and out like it
was very because I had seen all that in
other fights but
um with all the stakes on the line in
Brazil fighting for the title and I
think you were at your best I really do
yeah man I rise to the occasion I really
lock in like you know I understand I
understand the situation I understand
the most so that's why I work so hard to
get to it and then I trust the work that
I put in you know so at that point it's
just I do what you do every day